welcome to the live stream just going to
wait a second for people to get
connected lots to talk about today I'm
glad that you are joining me I am going
to focus quite a bit on the latest
attempt from Republicans to pass the
American Health Care Act without anybody
knowing what's going on with it but
before I get to that I do want to talk a
little bit about Jeff Sessions lowering
up now the Attorney General himself
getting a lawyer and sort of what this
means in the broader context of this
Russia investigation I'm also going to
be taking super chat questions and if
this happens to be your first live
stream I do want to tell you that yes
I'm really live right now unless you're
watching a replay of the live stream
because they are available for replay
number two super chat is on okay that is
on the YouTube platform the dollar sign
at the bottom which you can use to send
questions comments etc all that stuff
number three new members and patrons
will get live thank-yous and shout out
during the live stream so by all means
if you've been thinking about making a
contribution to the production of the
David Pakman show
there is really no better time to do it
than yesterday of course but second to
yesterday is during a live stream
membership is that david pakman.com
slash membership patreon is at
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
number four obvious trolling and hate is
going to get you banned if you're here
to insult people if you're here to
repeat make America great again or
David's a cuck Jew or whatever over and
over again you're going to get banned
and the moderators have been fully
deputized to ban as needed and I hope
that that will not happen
they will wield that tool carefully but
they will wield it if necessary subtle
trolling probably won't get you banned
now I am trying once again
at last time for the first time I tried
simultaneously streaming to youtube and
Facebook and it did not work on Facebook
I'm trying it again and I'm getting an
indicator that we are quote online on
Facebook live at facebook.com slash
david pakman show but I don't want to
navigate away from what I've got enough
stuff going on here I don't want to risk
creating a problem for the stream so if
you can go over and check and let me
know in the chat whether we are on
Facebook live if we're not I I don't
know what I'm doing wrong I'm using a
tool called restream dot IO which I'm
paying for this tool the whole point of
it is to stream to multiple platforms
simultaneously and I just don't know
what else I could do if it's not working
so if anybody can check on that by all
means please do let me jump right in
here and talk about what's going on with
the American Health Care Act I've been
talking for a little while now about how
because of the constant scandal of the
Donald Trump administration we're not
hearing anything anymore about that
bogus tax cut plan it's been a little
while since we last heard anything about
the American Health Care Act until the
last 24 to 48 hours we're not hearing
anything about build the wall and make
Mexico pay for it none of that stuff is
going on because Trump is basically just
dealing with scandal after scandal
we now are hearing about the American
Health Care Act again and Republicans in
the Senate because remember the
Republicans in the House have been
working on this nonsense for a while but
we're now hearing from Republicans in
the Senate including Mitch McConnell who
I inadvertently it was it was a Freudian
slip last week on the show called [ __ ]
McConnell and it genuinely was a
Freudian slip but people are isolating
that and turning it into various memes
Mitch McConnell is saying hey we're
going to vote on this thing Chuck
Schumer asked are we going to have time
to actually figure out what's in this
thing are we going to have more than 10
hours maybe and Mitch McConnell said
there's going to be plenty of time to
actually figure out what's in the bill
and craft amendments now that is
unlikely to be the case when Republicans
in the House voted to pass
the second version of the American
Health Care Act they deliberately did it
before anybody had time to figure out
what was in it because if you figure out
what's in it you realize how much of a
disaster it is and this was proven when
the Congressional Budget Office
ultimately came out with some analysis
where some I mean it's been weeks now
some millions of people are going to
lose their health care coverage and we
knew exactly why House Republicans were
rushing it through and it appears as
though House Senate Republicans want to
do the exact same thing this is people
rank issues right in terms of how much
does this issue matter how much does
that issue matter whatever the case may
be it is hard to imagine that right now
in in modern American society there are
bigger issues than number one health
care and whether we are going to say
everybody needs to have some basic level
of care or not and if you say no you
still are going to pay for it because
people will show up in the emergency
room instead of going to primary care
we've talked about it right health care
number two this issue of campaign
finance money in politics and that
connects to net neutrality in the fight
that's going on right now and you know
whatever issue you care about if you
care about education if you care about
women's reproductive rights if you care
about foreign policy whatever issue you
care about if you're not healthy you
can't really activate and be involved in
the democratic process and number two if
we don't have net neutrality if we have
a total lack of parity when it comes to
the influence of money in politics and
how a rich person versus a poor person
compares in terms of the influence that
they can wield then that's going to
affect you no matter what your most
important issue is and I've been making
this case for years at this point no
matter what issue you care about you
need to figure out how is that is our
financial interests dealing with that
issue and that includes media and that's
why net neutral
is so major because media right now in
great part means internet and people
need to be healthy another in order to
move on to higher order areas of life
this is sort of like Maslow's hierarchy
of needs at the top of the pyramid was I
believe it was self self-actualization
for example the bottom of the pyramid is
basic physical safety do you have enough
to eat is a lion about to eat you those
are the sort of basic needs in Maslow's
hierarchy of needs if you don't have
that you're going to have a real
difficult time moving on to those higher
order things along the same lines if you
don't have basic health care it's going
to be difficult if you are ill for you
to focus on foreign policy issues that
are relevant to you or whatever the case
may be and Maslow's hierarchy of needs
applies really really specifically I
think it's a really good analogy to what
we are seeing go on right now in in
modern American society so we've got to
get involved in what's going on with the
health care debate just like we've got
to get involved as I implored my
audience today to get involved with the
net neutrality situation that's going on
because it's bad and if you if you're
already concerned about the key media
issues that I've been talking about this
includes lack of diversity of voices
corporate influence on media false
balance false neutrality wrong stories
bias to sensationalism I mean there's a
list of twenty or thirty of these issues
if you care about that you've got to be
involved in what's going on with net
neutrality and I talked about it on the
program today and there's a lot more to
talk about as far as that goes and and
we're going to talk about it but in the
short term who is my representative is
it net who is my this is just like the
key website who is my representative com
you put in your zip code and it will
tell you and I'm doing it right now it
will tell you who are your
representatives and in the US House my
representatives are congressman Capuano
and
congressman Stephen Lynch my senators
are Ed Markey and Elizabeth Warren no
surprise there and you have contact
information listed there you've got to
get involved you've got to get involved
when it comes to health care you've got
to get involved when it comes to net
neutrality and the good news is there's
many issues where it just doesn't really
matter what we do right we know like
we're not really going to be able to
change campaign finance by calling a
Mitch McConnell and saying you know fix
campaign finance however we have a track
record of successfully defeating
horrific net neutrality attempt to
derail net neutrality and so on that
particular issue I encourage you to get
involved in call and of course on health
care you've got to do it if you can go
to a town hall even better okay
let's get to a couple of super chats and
then I'm going to get into the Jeff
Sessions stuff and p.m. everybody's
lawyering up at this point okay Frank
macwrite has used the dollar sign at the
bottom of the chat window for $20 to say
hey David Facebook does not seem to be
working fYI I asked a question before
about Republicans in health care now I
believe they just want to say they did
something doesn't matter if it's good or
helpful
do you agree yeah I mean so that there's
there's an issue that Republicans and
Trump are having right now which is
Trump campaigned hard on Obamacare is
out and he made totally untenable
promises because Obamacare is already so
right-wing remember it's fundamentally a
right-wing think tank idea from the
1990s this idea of we're going to let
private for-profit insurance companies
compete for tens of millions of
customers that the government will give
them and partially subsidized there's
nothing left wing about that idea and
this is what you need to fundamentally
understand you can't move the healthcare
status quo to the right any further
without some combination of increasing
price reducing access or and or reducing
quality of care so Trump's got a problem
because he campaigned on repeal and get
rid of Obamacare it hasn't happened so
far and so far the proposals have been
even worse tens of millions of more
people would be kicked off of health
care so Republicans do have
that problem Frank which is they need to
do something but what they're proposing
will make the problem worse and I don't
know where it's ultimately going to come
out floppy kid has sent a to Canadian
dollar super chat how do you think
history will remember Mitch McConnell I
don't know if history will have a
significant place for Mitch McConnell I
guess I'm saying the opposite which is I
don't know that Mitch McConnell is going
to have a significant place in history
maybe the next six months will prove me
wrong
Frank macwrite has sent another $20
super chat Frank macwrite the all-star
super chatter today so far
it feels like no one has a strong case
right now to pen trump but why would
lawyers get their own lawyers I know it
gives the impression they could be
implicated too but how likely is that is
that normal for lawyers Frank let me put
a pause on that because I'm going to get
to that next after I deal with it with
the last Super chat
Jacob ball sent the $5 super chat saying
did you watch Megyn Kelly's Alex Jones
interview what did you think of it you
know I didn't I did a story last week
giving my opinion about megyn kelly
interviewing Alex Jones I said I didn't
have any problem in principle I wasn't
offended that megyn kelly was
interviewing Alex Jones I did think that
it was sort of a letdown megyn kelly
leaves Fox News amidst major controversy
he's going to launch this Network show
on NBC News she gets Vladimir Putin for
the first episode and then all of a
sudden it's episode 2 and it's Alex
Jones that's your big get so I thought
the platform was too big for Alex Jones
but but frankly I was not offended by it
I didn't end up watching it though
because I just didn't care enough to
watch it
maybe I ultimately will okay so before I
get into Jeff Sessions very very quickly
I will let you know that we do have a
number of thank yous upcoming we are
funded by our viewers and when we get
people to sign up for membership during
the live stream at david pakman.com
slash membership those members are then
thanked profusely by me during the
stream ok so please please please sign
up at david pakman.com slash membership
your support does help to counteract the
destructive impact we've
lost 2/3 of our YouTube revenue as a
result of the YouTube advertiser boycott
and we're trying to make that money up
to keep the show unaffected and one of
the ways to do that is to sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership we do
an extra an extra show every day for our
paid members and if you would like a
discount off of the normal $6 a month
rate or $60 a year rate you can use the
coupon code I voted 17 as you see here
and that'll save you 40 percent you can
also go to patreon.com/scishow this is
way simpler than membership it's just if
you want to throw a dollar at our
production to make up for the lost
YouTube revenue you can do it at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
takes a second dollar a month that's all
you need to do you can do more if you
want and if every one of you that could
afford it right if you can't afford a
dollar a month don't do it but if you
can afford $1 a month if every one of
you did it the problem being caused for
us by the YouTube advertiser boycott
would basically be over overnight so
let's talk about lawyering up okay today
on the regular show I talked about it's
like it's I used this analogy because
we're dealing with Russia if you've ever
heard the term matryoshka doll those
Russian matryoshka dolls are those
successively smaller or bigger I guess
depending on where you start nested
dolls they're typically wooden where you
open one up and there's a slightly
smaller doll inside of it you open
another one is slightly smaller we've
got a similar scenario right now with
lawyers we have Donald Trump who was
advised by his lawyer Michael Cohen to
get another lawyer to represent him when
it comes to the Russia scandal Trump did
that he hired a guy named Mark Kassovitz
who by the way has no experience with
what's going on here then we learned
that Michael Cohen himself
Trump's lawyer has lawyered up lawyers
hiring lawyers and again Michael Collins
expertise is not in the type of heap of
trouble that he's getting himself into
by hit by virtue of his involvement with
the the Russia stuff so he has now
lawyer DUP vice-president Mike Pence he
has now
retained a personal lawyer to represent
him with all three current Russia
related investigations you've got the
widely discredited house investigation
you've got the Senate Intelligence panel
investigation into Russia and then you
have the panel of the investigation
rather now being led by special
prosecutor Robert Muller so Pence has
lawyered up
Trump's lawyer has lawyered up but we
have now learned above and beyond that
that Attorney General Jeff Sessions
effectively the top lawyer in the United
States has lawyered up think about that
the top lawyer in the United States now
has retained personal counsel because of
his potential implication in one of the
broadest and widest ranging
international geopolitical scandals of
our time there is there are attempts to
normalize all this so if you turn on
right-wing media you're going to hear
listen anytime you're being investigated
you're going to hire a lawyer that's
just being smart it's not evidence of
guilt of course hiring a lawyer is not
evidence of guilt that is one of the
main tenets of the American justice
system but the mere reality that five
months into Donald Trump's presidency -
the date is June twentieth he was
inaugurated on January twentieth five
months in the accomplishments of the
Trump administration are effectively nil
and multiple people have already
resigned and or been pushed out the
latest of course being Sean Spicer after
a board of performance after performance
on that in that White House press room
and multiple Trump associates now have
lawyers all related to possible
collusion with a foreign power a foreign
power that is not particularly friendly
to us and we're going to talk tomorrow
on the program about some of the other
angles that have developed when it comes
to this entire investigation and we've
been doing less of the Russia stuff
because I need to sort of put my money
where my mouth is or walk the talk a
walk the walk if I'm going to talk the
talk which is that progressives need to
be focused on issues above and beyond
the Russia investigate
and it's sort of obvious why which is
that if the Russian investigation
evaporates and leads to nothing
Democrats need to have issues that
they're running on for 2018 and 2020 if
the Russia investigation takes down
Trump and Trump's gone you no longer
have Trump to run against in 2018 or
2020 and then you definitely need a
platform so we've been talking less
about what's going on with Russia but we
are still talking about it and one of
the fascinating bits of information is
that Donald Trump's nominee to replace
James Comey at the Supreme Court
Christopher Rae of course James Comey
being fired by Trump and now Trump wants
to replace him with Christopher ray I
told you last week that he is Russia
connected that the law firm that he that
he works for has represented a number of
Russian clients that has been scrubbed
from the website of the law firm whose
name escapes me I believe it's King and
Spaulding and you know why is it always
Russia like why don't we hear about Oh
Trump was in the Oval Office and he
leaked secret classified information to
the President of Chile no it's never
it's never Chile it's never it's never
Costa Rica it's Russia why do we never
hear oh there were undisclosed meetings
with there were undisclosed meetings
with the Sri Lankan ambassador no it's
always undisclosed meetings with Russian
associates so we're going to talk about
that because the amount of smoke at this
point is getting to be truly nutty truly
truly nutty let me dig back into some of
the super chats that are going on here
let's see Nicki ray $10 super chat she
says I may have missed the video if you
did one but now how do you feel about
the Cuba reversal personally I see no
good reason to flip on it yeah Nicki you
didn't miss the video today's broadcast
the June 20th show I talked about Donald
Trump's reversal of some of the Obama
easing of the Cuban embargo I think it's
absolutely ridiculous it's it's totally
laughable and it makes no sense and and
you know all along the idea is well we
want to do what's good for Cubans if you
look at what Donald Trump has done
there's nothing about
that is good for Cubans so your spot-on
Nikki no doubt about it
Jorden Parsons has sent a dollar can a
Canadian dollar super chat no question
or comment thanks very much Frank
macwrite has sent a twenty dollar super
chat that is Frank's third twenty dollar
super chat today thanks very much Frank
saying apologize if you touched on this
on the full show today navigated a way
to join the live stream can you talk
about Cuba and what good reason there is
to change things because of a bad deal
as Trump calls it there's no reason to
change things with Cuba and the changes
that Donald Trump has made as you'll see
in the full show which by the way as a
member Frank gets Frank doesn't have to
wait for the four to eight minute videos
to be released throughout the evening by
4:00 4:15 p.m. Eastern Time every day as
a david pakman show member Frank gets
our entire broadcast one-hour show which
doesn't go live on free speech TV and on
DirecTV and Dish until 11:00 p.m.
Eastern Time our members like Frank get
that video around 4:15 p.m. Eastern so
sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership but you're right Frank it
doesn't make sense to reverse the Obama
easing on Cuba the idea for the
hypocritical maintaining of this embargo
with Cuba is we don't we don't support
their system of government right we want
to be anti-communist of course decades
of the embargo did nothing to ease
communism to remove communism or to
deter communism in Cuba and in fact the
easing of the embargo has done more to
move Cuba away from from from so-called
communism in that American for-profit
hotel chains have started to do deals in
Cuba right it's funny how we stopped
saying let's hold out to make them no
longer be communist and all of a sudden
you've got hotel chains entering Cuba so
it makes absolutely no no sense
whatsoever Frank
Athena Harding has sent a five-dollar
super chat saying your audio and video
is pretty out of sync thought I'd let
you know test it on multiple devices yet
you know Athena that seems to be an
issue every once in a while I'm on a
very fast wired connect
I'm not doing anything differently than
I normally do so I don't know what's
causing that unfortunately I will
continue trying to improve it a user who
goes by the name of Hitomi [ __ ] has sent
a dollar super Chad with no question or
comment mystic resistance has sent a
five-dollar super Chad saying David I'm
dreading things will get so bad for
Trump at some point that he will feel
the need for a big distraction and there
will be war with North Korea you know
what you're saying
some people might say that's crazy that
is crazy but I don't think it's crazy
III also worry that at any point when
Donald Trump when Donald Trump needs to
take attention away from a he'll do B
and B is usually pretty damn bad so I
don't think you are too cynical for
believing that Perseus Gold has sent a
$2 a to Canadian dollar super chat break
tech monopolies and big banks equal
fascist platform break tech monopolies
oh I see break the monopolies of
Technology and of big banks and that
that is a fascist platform I'm not
really sure about that uh-huh okay well
listen I uh
you're making a point about monopolies
and I think that we can all be grateful
for that right there you go wish I wish
I could have made it a little more out
of that okay I'm gonna do thank yous for
new members and and patrons in a second
but let me talk just about a couple of
other things if you didn't see Trump's
newest lawyer Trump has multiple lawyers
now and one of them is Jay Sekulow Jay
Sekulow is an extremist nut I mean
there's really no other way to say Jay
Sekulow was born Jewish meaning he's
from a family historically that is both
ethnically and religiously Jewish and if
you don't know the difference between
ethnic and religious Judaism if you
convert to Judaism
you are not ethnically Jewish unless at
some point right you
Ashkenazi or Sephardic or whatever the
case may be but you can also be born
ethnically Jewish and convert out of
Judaism as a religion you remain
ethnically Jewish but you might say I'm
a Christian I'm a Muslim whatever Jay
Sekulow was born Jewish and he converted
to Christianity which in and of itself
is already rare right I mean Jews are
very non-religious to begin with so it's
pretty rare that somebody who is born
Jewish would say I'm going to convert to
Christianity usually if you're not
feeling the the religious aspect of
Judaism you would say I'm just not
really religious right
Jay Sekulow converted to Christianity
but he considers himself a Messianic Jew
this is also sometimes called a Jew for
Jesus these are not always individuals
who are born Jewish in fact sometime
very often they're not and Messianic
Jews are again we're having a
conversation right now as if any of this
nonsense is anything but nonsense so I'm
kind of you have to buy into the
internal logic of it a Messianic Jew is
Jewish in that they follow the Old
Testament I guess and not the New
Testament with the exception that they
believe Jesus is the Messiah it's really
wacky anyway so this whacked out guy
Trump saw him on Fox News and said
that's who I'm gonna hire that guy to
also be part of my legal team on this
Russia stuff and Jay Sekulow did a bunch
of interviews over the weekend one of
which was with Chris Wallace on Fox News
Sunday and he almost in the same breath
said Trump is not under personal
investigation and Trump is personally
under investigation I won't rehash the
entire thing you really have to see the
clip to believe it and that clip will be
going live soon if it hasn't already
kind of remember when we had that one
scheduled for I don't remember exactly
but that'll be going live soon and it's
it's worth seeing and of course please
check out our story about Sean Spicer
being out as press secretary that's
already live that went live a couple
hours ago on our YouTube channel and a
lot of wild and wacky stuff happening
no no doubt about that okay let me do a
few thank-yous we are viewer supported
media and the one there's really only
one way that we will be able to weather
the storm of the YouTube advertiser
boycott and that is if we make up for
the 2/3 lost YouTube revenue with
patreon and membership support so I want
to make a big big thank you for Shannon
Weston who just what we've been chatting
here has pledged two dollars a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
listen I'm really not asking here for a
it's not a big ask what I'm saying is if
you can afford a dollar a month pledge
$1 a month at patreon.com slash david
pakman show that will undo the damage of
the YouTube advertiser boycott but by
set by a couple orders of magnitude
really so big big thank you to Shannon
Weston for making that pledge I also
want to send a couple of membership
thank-yous Pete Plummer Pete Plummer has
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership using the coupon code
I voted 17 Marie Mitchell has signed up
at david pakman.com slash membership
using the coupon code
I voted 17 of course after you select
your membership you click the red sign
up button and on the second page you'll
see this coupon code field if you want a
40% discount and listen you don't have
to take it you don't have to take that
discount if if the discount is
meaningful to you if the normal prices
are higher than you are comfortable with
then by all means use the coupon code
and that's exactly what Michael Gilbert
did just in the last half-hour so what
we've been chatting here as well as
Katherine Benson Katherine Benson has
also signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership and every member really you
know we we have the studio now and the
program is we were lucky enough that
we've had the level of audience growth
over the last few years where we have
staff now we have a proper studio where
i don't do the show adam
mom's basement or something like that or
out of a community radio basement which
which is where we started this has
happened because of the growth of the
audience and because a fraction of the
audience chooses to become David Pakman
show members now this is something that
a lot of people don't know or understand
or sort of have any sense of and why
would you right I mean you're living
your life we estimate that somewhere
around half to one percent of our
audience contributes financially to the
show either through membership or
through patreon or through using our
Amazon affiliate link david pakman.com
slash amazon so that means that for
every hundred to 200 viewers and
listeners on average one person has said
i'm going to make a financial
contribution here if we could get the
percentage of our audience that supports
us financially to just 2% it would be an
it would upend the status quo of the
david pakman show it would beyond undo
the damage of the YouTube advertiser boy
cat and I know it's really easy to say
well I'm not going to contribute someone
I could do $1 a month but someone else
will the dollar a month doesn't really
make a difference I'm sure there's lots
of people that contribute we estimate
that it is half to one percent of the
audience that contributes financially
and if we can just tweak that number up
just a hair it really makes a big
difference okay so we will I'll continue
doing thank-yous as as we go here sign
up patreon etc okay Tony Merritt has
sent the five British pound super chat
hey David I know you're a drummer any
plans to record music at any point in
the future yeah I am a drummer but all
I've got at my place is a practice pad
because since I live in an apartment in
Boston I can't have I for noise reasons
I can't have my acoustic drums and for
space reasons I can't have a pair a set
of a kit an electronic drum kit which
would be the way to be sort of quiet in
an apartment with drum so I don't
currently have
a lot of new material that I might be
able to record but I'd love to get back
into a band situation sooner than later
Jordan Parsons a to Canadian dollar
super Chad what do you think of the EPA
shenanigans of late you know I'm not
sure exactly what you're referring to
Jordan I mean I know broadly what's
going on at the EPA with Scott Pruett
but I actually have not been following
the specifics as of late but I will look
into it
I'm going to make a note right now to
look into what's going on now with the
EPA unless you mean just the normal
incompetence in corruption
Rebecca page has sent a $10 super chat
give a shout-out to my mom test black we
love your show
keep up the great work hello Tess and
thanks so much for the support Rebecca
appreciate that and and it's a it's a
very important time for us because
interest in politics
has not been higher in a very very long
time given the election of Donald Trump
and yet because of the the two-thirds
revenue reduction that we're
experiencing because of the YouTube ad
boycott it's a complex situation where
we have the biggest opportunity to grow
that that we've had in a long time but
we also are sort of trying to make up
for a revenue deficit that we're
experiencing Herbert Holmes has sent the
$20 super chat with a very important
question can you touch on the issue of
science illiteracy in America yeah
there's a couple there's two layers of
science illiteracy there's sort of
general science illiteracy and it
connects to lack of critical thinking
skills and there's also problems with
reporting on science so let's take them
in opposite order I have been doing a
lot to educate myself about how to be a
better science reporter now I'm because
we report mostly on politics
I'm realistically not going to be as
good at reporting on science as people
who were exclusively doing science
reporting but I want to make every
effort and this prequel who wonder what
is David doing when he's not you know
doing the show I'm trying to educate
myself to make the show better and to
make
myself better prepared to talk about
stories with you every day I have made
an effort to educate myself I've done a
couple of online courses on science
reporting and science journalism and
it's a lot of basics right always look
at the source study very often the
summaries or headlines that are written
from studies are not very are not
accurate straight up and sometimes
they're not complete look at the you
have to understand the basics of science
studies as they are often done with with
regard to medicine which is what was our
sample size what's the confidence
interval
are there confounding factors separating
correlation and causation which is
really really important a classic one is
hey studies show vegetarians live longer
interesting do studies show vegetarians
live longer because they are vegetarians
completely different question
representative of what is often missing
from science journalism and science
reporting so that's number one the
separate issue which might be the one
you're talking about more directly
Herbert is that many people don't
understand science and this includes
comparisons or likening science to a
religion right oh the scientific method
is no different than other than religion
it's just you know people who have
dogmatic beliefs that they stick to it's
either the New Testament or its
scientists at NASA whatever Peter
Boghossian does a really good job in his
book Emanuel for creating atheists of
providing some ways to dispute that
right I mean science is not like a
religion science has science is not a
closed loop where scientific assertions
are checked and balanced out by so much
else of what we know religion doesn't
have that if you go to your pastor and
you say I'm kind of doubting I'm kind of
doubting that really that Noah's Ark was
a real thing you think they're going to
tell you you know explore that by
looking into the science of whether
Noah's Ark was possible no they're going
to tell you well you know what you've
really got to go and read your Bible
it's a closed loop the other issue is
that science
has encouraged self-correcting for a
very very long time so when people say
science is no different than religion in
religion you're not cheered for coming
up with unique ideas like maybe Noah's
Ark wasn't possible after all that's not
something your pastor is going to cheer
in science if you can debunk what is
considered at the time the mainstream
consensus of science you will actually
be applauded and the bigger and more
important the scientific consensus that
you can debunk the more famous you will
be and the more accolades that you will
reap so there's such a lack of literacy
as Herbert is pointing out and these are
just a couple of the issues and I know
that there's way more it's only sort of
you know superficial but yeah I mean
Herbert absolutely absolutely good point
Jerry Jerome has sent what is now our
top super chat for the evening out doing
Herbert homes in Frank macwrite although
Frank has sent three $20 super chats
Jerry Jerome with a $25 super chat the
invisible committee DuckDuckGo it thanks
David okay I will I will look that up
DuckDuckGo an alternative to Google I
don't know about the invisible committee
I'm not endorsing it I have no idea what
it is it might be for all I know it's
some crazy conspiracy theory I genuinely
have no idea whatsoever but I will check
it out five-second has sent a to
Canadian dollar super chat man afford
daughter cell phone hack comments oh
yeah I thought that that was an old an
old story
cell phone hack let me google that did
it happen again like I have a feeling
that they were hacked before yeah those
stories seemed to be from February in
March so we covered that story at the
time five second and I don't have any
new comments I don't think that there's
anything any new information about it so
I wouldn't have too much more to say let
me get caught up on a new members and
patreon contributions I don't want to
fall behind on this huge thank you huge
thank you to peg foo trel peg Ferrell
has just
alleged $2 a month at patreon.com slash
david pakman show thank you so much I
really appreciate that and if we could
get you know we've got about 700 people
right now on the stream if we could get
just 5% of you right about 35 of you to
make a contribution of even $1 a month
at patreon.com that would be huge that
would put us almost over 1,600
contributions which would be major
absolutely major also let me do a couple
of membership thank-yous Suzanne Moore
Marinka vich I hope I'm saying that
correctly has just signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership using none
other than the 40% discount coupon code
that you see here
I voted 17 all one word all lowercase
thank you I really really do appreciate
that
I also want to say a major thank you to
Nathaniel Williamson who has signed up
not only opting not to use the coupon
code signing up for a $12 per month
membership which you are able to do at
your pleasure if that is something that
is interesting to you so Thanks so you
know we there's no there's it's not us
people say David how is your show funded
I don't really get it you're on these
200 radio and TV stations do they pay
for the radio show and TV show no they
don't the 200 community radio and TV
stations that were on often in very red
areas you should go to david pakman.com
slash stations and look up the places
where the show airs very very red areas
often on the only progressive radio
station in the town or city we give them
the show we give them the show for free
because a lot of those radio stations
don't really have budgets for
programming so not only do you great get
great member benefits when you become a
member you're also funding the
distribution of the show to red areas
and I think that there's a lot of
progressives that would feel pretty good
about that especially if you consider
the right-wing dominance of talk radio
the fact that when you contribute $1 a
month at patreon or 3.60 cents a month
through membership you're not only
getting cool stuff including the bonus
show and all of that you're actually
putting progressive media on in red
areas and hard to hard to get more
excited than that believe me they don't
like it with it the number of complaints
that our progressive radio stations get
because they air our show in red areas I
get them forwarded all the time and it
is it's stunning it is stunning getty
germany has sent a 2 euro super chat do
not forget cobb feffy act yes cobb feffy
act I think Getty Germany might have
mentioned that last time Cobb feffy act
don't forget it
ok Mahmoud ur Siddiqui I hope I'm
pronouncing that close to correctly sent
a ten dollar super chat thank you for
your support
chairwoman of transparency international
Bangladesh is facing violent threat from
Islamists and state-sponsored censorship
for speaking out against removing statue
of Lady Justice would you cover it I
will look into it
absolutely I will make a note right now
thank you for the suggestion and I will
look into that story after the show and
it may make it on to our show
game fire 74 has sent a seven dollar and
sixty five cent super chat saying it's
hashtag too soon but number one does
anyone believe that Congress people
carrying guns make them safer and number
two thoughts on depraved PAC ad against
John Asif I have not seen the ad against
John Asif I've been keeping up with that
race but I have not seen the ad as far
as the the Congress people carrying guns
thing you know we can all imagine
situations where if a particular member
of Congress had a gun it might appear as
though that would have been good it
would have increased the overall safety
of whoever was around at the time with
regard to the shooting of Steve Scalise
I want to remind you that they were
playing baseball at the time and listen
I don't know
how guns and baseball uniforms work but
would they have had their guns on them
as they were out on the baseball field I
mean we can imagine a situation where
someone could be attacked while they
have a gun but would it actually have
made a difference remember it was the
police officers who had the oh you know
what I'm sorry I've got a band someone
there's just something just caught my
eye and I'm just sick of some of the
nonsense that's going on here okay
got it thank you it was the police
officers who were not playing baseball
at the time who actually had had the
guns and were able to neutralize the the
shooter so you know I think whenever
whenever we talk about guns and safety
just because we can imagine a situation
where an individual could have been
safer presumably if they had had a gun
doesn't mean that we should make policy
on that and that relates also to this
you know when we talk about the death
penalty
I can imagine as an individual who is
against the death penalty something that
might happen to someone I love member of
my family friend whatever where I would
want the revenge of the death penalty
that doesn't mean that we should make
public policy based on that and again
revenge the state is not really supposed
to be in the business of revenge so I
think it's it's it's dicey to make
public policy based on anecdotes okay
jerry jerome adding another $25 super
chat pakman a voice of reason and
intellectualism parentheses capital a I
don't know what parentheses capital a
means but I appreciate it thank you so
much Jerry mystic resistance is cent a
$5 super chat David serious question
would you ever consider running for
office well I could never be President
under current American law because I was
not born in the United States although I
am a citizen I have papers if one were
to ask for them I was not born in the US
and thus would not be able to be
president would I consider running for
something else I would but I would
really only do it if I truly believed
that putting time into that instead of
whatever else I'm doing at the time
would be sort of a net positive for
society could I really make an impact
and I don't know what that position
would be it'd be something I'd have to
think about pretty pretty carefully but
it's certainly something that that I
would consider if the circumstances were
to be the the right ones let me say a
couple of more thank-yous because I
don't want to fall behind
Daniel Frank dis has pledged $5.00 per
month at patreon.com slash David Pakman
show
I really really appreciate that every
single one of these pledges and you know
just what we've been chatting here it's
been a dollar here and two dollars there
and five dollars now these numbers start
to add up when you talk about thousands
of patrons and twelve months out of the
year a dollar a month starts to add up
quickly so if you're saying to yourself
I'm not going to contribute because I
can only do a dollar a month I say to
you no no no that's why you should
contribute because you know that a
dollar a month is the number that works
for you that is a contribution that you
should make also on the membership side
members get the commercial free audio
and video stream of the show as well as
the bonus show and lots of other great
member benefits I want to send a few
other thank-yous out Sharon McCabe
Sharon McCabe has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership Sally Tuttle
Sally Tuttle has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership using the
coupon code
I voted 17 the coupon code will be
changing soon I don't know if it will
remain at a 40% discount this is a great
time to use that coupon code what better
time than now I also want to say thank
you to Kevin Pollak Kevin well that's
funny I just realized Kevin Pollak the
last names is spelled in some other way
so it is not the Kevin Pollak but it is
a Kevin Pollak that's really important
to us let's put it that way has signed
up at david pakman.com slash membership
so thank you thank you very much
appreciated and lastly Preston ring Rose
Preston ring Rose
lined up at david pakman.com slash
membership Jacob ball has sent a
five-dollar super chat quoting me who
just said five minutes ago
I don't know how guns and baseball
uniforms work David Pakman 2020 to be
clear I know how guns work I know how
baseball uniforms work I don't know how
they work together I don't know how they
work together and that's what I meant
alright we're going to stop this stream
at 45 minutes I actually do a lot more
work to do on tomorrow's program to have
that ready for you check out our
long-form piece on political correctness
it was uploaded yesterday people are
loving it or hating it I'm getting
tweets about it Dave Rubin a sargon of
akkad all these different people being
mentioned in tweets about the political
correctness video check it out the truth
about political correctness thanks for
joining me I'll do another stream soon